hey there everyone back in 2012 you may
recall I went on a bit of a a Yahtzee
binge it started with me recording a one
roll Yahtzee I have done it
mr. tapes about to end but I've done it
and from there you all went a bit crazy
sending me your own versions 81 rolls
highly tau
oh shoot now even now a few years later
I'm still receiving one roll yachties
from you and I love getting them I
thought I'd show you a few more today
but to mark the occasion I thought I'd
also do something a little bit special
myself Here I am attempting a one roll
Yahtzee but this time not with five but
six dice and six pink dice because well
that's a bit of a numberphile trademark
isn't it and I'm not just recording it
I'm attempting to capture it with a
super slow-motion camera and there's my
little chihuahua Audrey on hand of
course but before we do that let's have
a look at a few more videos that have
come in from you the viewers he is caleb
doing the deed in like a true
numberphile he's also tallied all the
stats every combination of four of a
kind three of a kind love your attention
to detail Caleb and Carrie while she was
joined by her excited sister when she
defied the odds with 571 rolls now of
course another way to defy the odds is
to go industrial and that's what they
did at this school in New Jersey
hello numberphile hello Brady I'd like
you to introduce you to mr. heads math
class everyone give away as much as we'd
love to roll one set of dice at a time
due to the complexities of middle school
scheduling we don't have two and a half
hours to sit around doing this so we're
gonna do this on a rapid-fire scale 24
students at a time and we'll see how
long it takes before we do since we love
the sound of sharpies on brown paper
everyone pick up your sharpie make a few
squeaks yeah
perfect one of us will be the factory
worker in Willy Wonka getting the golden
ticket
are we ready class okay grab 24 roll
grab 48 roll and I think you get the
picture what's going on here so let's
just a fast-forward a little bit
504 roll grab Yahtzee on the five
somewhere around the 500 and fourth roll
everyone give a round of applause and it
was with four great work there but now
let's get back to my six pink dice but
before the moment of truth here are a
few puzzles for those of you who like a
bit of homework with six dice how likely
do you think one of these is a straight
one two three four five six
why don't you calculate the odds on that
one or how about the likelihood of five
of a kind without the sixth matching
dice but I'm not going to ask you to
calculate the odds of this one dice
landing perched on top of another but
here's the moment you've been waiting
for the six dice the six pink dice one
roll Yahtzee at 1,600 frames per second
it took me a little under 1,100 rolls I
think that counts a little bit
unreliable
if you missed our Yahtzee extravaganza
back in 2012 it's still there in all its
glory links are on the screen and in the
video description and a special shout
out and thanks to those people on the
screen at the moment their patreon
supporters they give a little bit extra
to numberphile we appreciate it
and some of you this month have a few
little bonuses coming out in the post so
thanks a lot now where are the dice what
do you reckon 7 dice 1 roll Yahtzee